alors attendez où est-ce qu'on est ici
déjà parce que
le temps du tout de me dire où on était
et je suis le premier je l'explique
quand même c'est le premier fusil de
police non voyant engagé dans la force
publique sur la rue on va le problème
c'est que les collègues sont partis sans
me dire on était alors on est rompre
alors on est au rond-point des
Champs-Élysées là attendez on a le
bouquin on va se le partager vous voulez
aller rue de la Paix ouais alors
regardez qu'est-ce que vous nous lisez
là
on veut pas ça
voilà alors rue de Paris alors on va
chercher le rue de la Paix c'est quel
arrondissement vous connaissez vous
parce que moi je suis pas d'ici
voilà ah ben voilà un collègue justement
peut-être là peut-être moi
dites-moi il y a le chef qui a demandé
vous fassiez la circulation
je suis désolé je suis désolé je trouve
que le chef va travailler bien ouais
d'accord
vous voulez pas demander au collège
ça se passe bien c'est tranquille on a
l'arme parce que l'arme c'est une vraie
l'arme à moi aussi j'ai diminué comme
vous alors je trouvais pas ça étrange
que bah non j'ai pas trouvé ça parce que
j'aime bien votre modèle de lettre qui
commence à être branché dans la police
ah ouais non mais on peut être dans la
on peut être dans la police et branché
dites-moi comme je suis le premier
officier de police non voyant dans la
brigade
le Palais de la Découverte alors écoutez
venez voilà venez on va partager on va
partager le plan là regardez voilà mais
non mais on est tout près hein
normalement oui bah donc vous allez un
collègue tiens justement voilà un
collègue monsieur
alors regardez le chef qui a demandé ce
que vous fassiez la chef
alors là on est où là voilà non mais là
là
vous êtes pas du tout on est pas du tout
parce que je vous demande c'est ce que
je veux
effectivement c'est voilà un collègue
justement là il y a un collègue voilà il
va peut-être venir nous aider finalement
vous fassiez la circulation d'accord bon
ben écoutez
ben si ben écoutez c'est les heures du
chef c'est genre du chef si tu veux
commencer tu comprends une chose le chef
ne dit jamais de oppo ridicule
c'est mon service c'est mon service j'ai
choisi j'ai choisi
[Musique]